hello everyone I'm Karen Gordon with
Phil encourage the radio show we had a
wonderful interview with ride the divide
executive producer Mike Dion and rather
divided producer Joe Cantwell and we're
curious about the music and ride the
divide and understand you had some great
indie bands that were part of a CD
that's actually been sold so while we
were kind of curating music for for the
film with that with the route going
through British Columbia Montana along
the along the Rockies we knew that kind
of wanted to fit that vibe a little bit
of singer-songwriter and not so much
western but started really kind of
seeking and curating musicians from that
region so started searching actually was
using sonicbids com which is a pretty
great sort of place to to curate
musicians it's a place where musicians
put up their BIOS and their information
in hopes of mostly sort of things like
South by Southwest and and bars and
clubs to kind of find find musicians to
help fill fill their event or bore their
venues and as well kind of falls into
the film and TV aspects we started
searching for in British Columbia
Montana Colorado New Mexico and actually
found musicians about half the half the
music in the soundtrack are actually
from musicians in that region and it's
obviously resonated to an audience
because in the Q&A sessions pretty it's
often someone will always reference
where did you guys you know find the
music it fits so perfectly with with you
know what you were showing it and the
feeling in the mood and hopefully that's
kind of why why that comes across that
way so
and not only did your team book
theatrical screenings but you also had
audience members doing the same thing or
enthusiasts of the film and you had one
person in particular that actually
worked to curate the film's through the
Midwest and several places exactly and
not just a Midwest actually Gary
Harrington who was been a fan of the
film is an endurance runner himself just
the movie kind of spoke to him and he
found a way to encompass his work and
his passion by leveraging ride the
divide screens in cities pretty much
across America so we'll coordinate on
market see if we're going to do a city
with a theatrical screening event then
then we may host that and handle that
but Gary has been going to places where
frankly we would never be able to travel
at all and putting on screenings himself
and as a promoter pretty much paying a
licensing fee to the filmmakers to say
I'll take the city or this handful of
cities I'll put on the event and he does
everything same thing that you do that
we do to bring an audience into the
experience he will do in cities all
across the country so it's ad kind of a
third layer to support the film but it's
all done as essentially he's in a
promoter it's been a great model for us
to to build on and it could be
appropriate for other filmmakers as well
I'm wondering to what have you found has
really worked to get people in seats and
what hasn't worked I mean it's tough you
can just put an ad in the paper and
think that people are going to show up
to your film but often case that isn't
what happens what has worked and what
hasn't worked so I think for for us is
definitely going after your particular
nation with Facebook and Twitter I think
you can definitely go find where those
big groups exist it takes a little bit
of mining on Facebook you know finding
funding the groups and the clubs and
liking them and and getting in touch
with them and when I say like them you
know I think once you like someone on
facebook it enters you to be able to
send them messages or get in touch with
you know the organizer of that
particular group and then really
striking up conversations and in
partnerships we've gone into places
where we'll work with a cycling
nonprofit profits for instance in
Boulder Colorado the boulder mountain
bike alliance so so we partnered with
them let's say they've got a news
letter of 9,000 people so so we worked
out where an X percent of all revenue
from a particular show in boulder
colorado will benefit the boulder
mountain bike alliance so then we've
partnered up and then they'll go and hit
their newsletter list i'll hit their
facebook list and then we'll go ahead
and do our particular marketing again
through our facebook our newsletter list
and then whatever the local weekly that
you can get to not only just just talk
put a post but actually if you can get
them to to actually cover your story now
you almost kind of have to create
something rather than hey here's my film
playing in X market but what's unique
about your film for us the hook you know
I think the longest mountain bike race
from the world is is kind of newsworthy
and has helped us but it's it's tapping
that network and in really partnering
with them and giving them an incentive
of a dollar of each ticket or a
percentage of all ticket sales to and
help them get out and want to go market
your event and then the old found sorry
the old facist Street teams it never
hurts that feed on the street if you can
do it so we've been hoping in cities
from Boulder to philly to Dallas to you
name it we're putting up the posters
we're putting up flyers for handing them
out of Mike shops we're going and
introducing ourselves to the owners of
the bike shops and asking them to
personally put up post cards and flyers
and posters and get the word out and so
it's not it's not the most scalable tool
but nothing beats a handshake and
personal introduction feet on the street
and really communicating one moment and
not only for for theatrical you know if
someone doesn't show of theatrical e but
the project still sparks their interest
you know it could be something where I
week down the road or a munch down the
road or two months down the road well
you might see something from a DVD sale
or some other partnership arise so so
really you can't think of pretty much
anything you do if you do it right in
and from from from the harbor for the
good reasons is going to benefit either
your you or the project or something
either immediately or down the road